Binh dự!
Bây giờ thì nóng này chúng mặt nè
có những nhiều tớ như mà chị em hẹp goner với mình khảm ọi cái cái riêng phát dùi nốt tất cả
Rồi thì cường đồu tạm sấu vào cái mấy đồ xe
Suyên có đặc ở dưới, thích nắng nóng
Cái khột hóa khả mình khi mình chuyển đụng nói gì cubed là một thật dinker cơm đại
Thì cáo khi phải là Hoặc là tụi chình, đó nóng trách đi nghiêm
Đại đứa chân lên kào tụi chân lực tèo
và lứa đụi chữ ngoài chuyện hồi chữ tự nhiêu
Điều đăng rất lúc gắng để hoàn thành được cái nhiệm vũ mà đánh.
Nhưng chân cũng đổi dòng phó cho.
Cần tối mạnh mẹ mẹ tởi 2 và vấn dự.
Nhưng chân thích đánh đẹp của mình.
Nếu chân thích đánh đẹp, hình dị tởi 2 và nhìn chắc dị.
Cũng cũng phải không nhìn bố bất lý.